Margaery Tyrell: House Tyrell trace our descent
to Garth Greenhand, the legendary first King
of the Reach, who made the land bloom.
But so too does every noble house around us.
It seems dear ancestor Garth planted as many
flowers as he plucked.
A king should have more consideration for
his line, don't you think?
For over a thousand years, the Greenhand's
sons and grandsons ruled the Reach as House
Gardener.
The offshoots of his daughters grew into vast
and powerful houses in their own right.
Except for House Tyrell.
We chose instead to serve our Gardener cousins
faithfully as stewards.
To manage their stronghold of Highgarden and
the daily affairs of the Reach.
Our words are "Growing Strong."
And under our stewardship, the Reach did just
that.
As did we.
Until a blundering king almost cost us everything.
Aegon Targaryen had landed in Westeros.
King Mern allied us with the Rock to repel
the upstart's army.
One can only marvel that King Mern did not
reconsider when he saw the living dragons
against him.
Perhaps he should have sought counsel from
his trusted stewards before he set out.
Then again, perhaps he did.
At the Field of Fire, Aegon, and let us not
forget his sisters, burned the combined armies
of the Reach and Rock.
King Mern paid for his misjudgment with his
life and that of his ancient family.
In a day, the Reach had lost its king, its
ruling house, and most of its army.
Thankfully for everyone, my ancestor, Harlen
Tyrell, had better sense.
Until the maesters sorted out the entail among
Mern's cousins, Harlen, the steward was acting
lord of Highgarden.
To ensure peace and life in the Reach, he
would yield the castle of Aegon.
The other castles and families would then
follow, as they had since the Dawn Age.
Aegon had a continent to conquer, and the
fertile Reach was too valuable to raze.
He accepted Harlen's proposal and welcomed
our lands into his kingdom.
To show his gratitude, Aegon entitled Harlen
to Highgarden, the castle his family had served
for a thousand years, and made House Tyrell
his Wardens of the South, choosing us over
older, greater families in the Reach.
Our House thus owed everything to the Targaryens.
So is it any wonder we stayed true to King
Aerys, even during his madness, and even after
Robert Baratheon rebelled.
Some may question my father for laying siege
to the Baratheon's home instead of marching
to aid Prince Rhaegar before Robert could
kill him and scatter the royal army.
But let us not forget we had already dealt
Robert his only defeat of the war at Ashford.
If Lord Tywin Lannister had not "vanquished"
the Mad King so suddenly, our siege would've
destroyed Robert's home and his brothers and
won the war for Aerys.
But when the Targaryens fell, House Tyrell
again chose peace and prosperity over war
and devastation, and bent the knee to King
Robert Baratheon, First of His Name.
Randyll Tarly: The Andals swept across Westeros,
destroying many ancient families and kingdoms.
When the invaders arrived at the Reach led
by Ser Alester Tyrell, House Gardener chose
accommodation over the battle, hoping honors
and marriages would sate foreigners' ambition.
The Tyrells were welcomed into service as
hereditary stewards of Highgarden.
Thousands of years later, they repaid the
Gardeners for their acceptance.
When Aegon Targaryen declared that Westeros
was now his, King Mern IX allied with King
Loren Lannister of the Westerlands.
Together, they fought to save Westeros from
another foreign barbarian whose family practices
put decent men to shame.
But the dragons won.
The Field of Fire claimed Mern and all his
sons, grandsons, and brothers.
Instead of using the castle for what it was
built to do, Harlen Tyrell surrendered it
to Aegon without a fight.
In exchange, Harlen was given the castle his
family had served for thousands of years with
all its attendant lands and lords, including
my family.
Margaery Tyrell: Some Great Houses call us
upstarts, but the truth is that while the
Starks and Lannisters fell to the Targaryens
in defeat, House Tyrell rose.
For thousands of years, our family served
as loyal stewards to the Kings of the Reach.
Until the last of their line unwisely burned
to death, resisting the Targaryen invaders.
To save the Reach from a similar fate, we
yielded Highgarden to Aegon and his sisters.
In gratitude, the Targaryens gave House Tyrell
dominion over the Reach, and we became lords
of the castle in which, for generations, we
had served.
Under the Targaryen dynasty, Westeros prospered.
Gone were the petty wars of Seven Kingdoms
and the endless thirst for minor glories that
drove them.
The Westerlands enriched the realm, the North
guarded it, and the Reach and Riverlands fed
it.
This harmony is what Robert Baratheon shattered
with his rebellion against Aerys Targaryen.
When the call to arms came, though, we did
not want to answer.
The Reach is a gentle land, and, honestly,
the Mad King was not much loved.
But we owed peace and status to his family.
My father, Mace Tyrell, called his banners
and marched north to battle the rogue Storm
Lord, Robert, who had already defeated three
forces in a single day.
And, at Ashford, my father won.
Some chasten my father for not pursuing Robert
after the battle.
We had cut him off from the Stormlands, the
seat of his power, and he had fled north,
within easy grasp of Lord Tywin Lannister,
the Hand of Aerys for twenty years.
My father moved instead to lay siege of Robert's
ancestral stronghold of Storm's End.
The rose would strangle the stag as the lion
pounced.
So we waited.
But the lion slumbered, and Robert slipped
past the King's forces to join Ned Stark.
We could have lifted the siege and deployed
our armies north to aid the Crown.
We could have stormed the walls of the castle
and made Robert homeless.
But we had ample supplies, control of land
and sea, and, most of all, patience.
Our siege would succeed, eventually, at little
cost of life to us.
If Robert prolonged the war with minor victories,
our capture of Storm's End would hasten his
downfall.
And if Robert won the war, well, it would
not do for him to find us within his walls
with the bodies of his brother Stannis and
his sworn men.
When the lion finally showed his colors and
"purged" King's Landing, we knew our cause
was lost.
My father chose the peaceful route and bent
the knee to Robert, who heartily pardoned
us.
Strange, considering how we had beaten him
and starved his brother to the brink of death.
We were to keep our lands, castle, and title,
But we knew we would never be welcome at court.
It didn't matter.
The Reach was still the most fertile of the
Seven Kingdoms and under our hand.
Every flower, even the rose, needs pruning.
Then it grows strong.
Margaery Tyrell: The Reach is aptly named.
We're the ones who give your hands something
to do at the table.
As the most fertile region of the Seven Kingdoms,
we grow the lion's share of the grains and
fruit that feed this country, especially now
since the "rebels" have burned down the other
fields.
Yet as with all gardens, weeds grow in the
Reach too, though few name them as such.
Singers fill our heads with chivalry and courtly
love.
Fluff to make boys fight and girls swoon.
Oh, the songs are good enough for a pleasure
barge down the Mander.
They give pleasure to the common people and
harmony to the realm.
But if the rise of House Tyrell proves anything,
it's that virtue and honor have their place.
And if you're not careful, that place is the
grave.
Unlike the Lannisters, Starks, and Arryns,
we were never kings in our own right.
House Gardener ruled the Reach since the Dawn
Age, and we were their stewards.
While they warred to enrich their already
rich domain, we managed their castle of Highgarden.
But then Aegon Targaryen landed with his dragons.
Nobody knows why the Gardener King took the
field up against him.
Anyone could see that a man who grows flowers
should beware a man who grows fire-breathing
monsters.
But maybe it wasn't wholly his idea.
Maybe someone whispered in his ear about all
the face he would lose with the other six
kings if he stayed home.
The rest is history.
The last Gardener King lost his face, along
with his body, and his steward Harlen Tyrell
promptly yielded Highgarden to Aegon.
My grandmother swears that Harlen was like
most of our men and grew up banging steel
too loudly for thought to penetrate, but luckily
his wife had better sense.
Whatever the case, in return for Harlen's
show of sense, Aegon proclaimed House Tyrell
the lords of the Reach and Wardens of the
South, passing over all the other houses with
better claims.
Yet Aegon chose us.
Centuries later, when his descendant, Aerys,
faced rebellion, the Reach stayed loyal.
Mostly.
My father, Mace, dealt Robert his only defeat
in the war, even if it was my father's vanguard
who did most of the fighting before he arrived.
After the Battle of Ashford, we laid siege
to Storm's End, Robert's home.
Unfortunately, the war ended before we could
take it and free up our armies to go save
the king.